The next topic that I'll be
speaking about is going to be
managing your application.
And what this means is when
something is not going as
planned, how do you
troubleshoot that?
Where do you look, and
what do you do?
And finally, how would you
control some of the details
about budgeting your
application?
With troubleshooting, we'll
discuss the System Status page
and how to use the
Admin Console.
There's a lot of information
about the quota.
How you would set it,
how you'd use it.
And then lastly, we'll
discuss how and why
you'd enable billing.
And once you're billing is
enabled, how you'd set the
different budgets for
your application.
We'll also touch a little on
how this relates and the
differences between a premier
account and a standard online
billed application.
So if something stopped in your
Legacy environment, you
could actually log into
your server and
see a lot of details--
the operating system,
the app, how it's
running, what it's doing.
But in the cloud, you lose
a little bit of control.
We still provide a lot of tools
that we give you so that
you can troubleshoot your
application and identify where
those problems are, but there's
a different way of
thinking about things.
If nothing else, you could be
sitting in any data center.
If you think about a traditional
environment having
to aggregate those logs and
present them in one common
format, it would be
very challenging.
And so what we strive very
hard to do is to keep it
simple so that you can leverage
the power of our
infrastructure without
having to worry about
tweaking a lot of knobs.
So now, I'd like to talk a
little bit about where you'd
look when problems do arise.
If your application's returning
errors in every
request, the first thing
you want to do
is check a few things.
The first is, is your
application actually running?
Did you have a different
version deployed?
Is the default version the right
version that you have?
But then you would very quickly
look to see if you
have any errors in your log.
We aggregate all the
logs in the Admin
Page for every request.
In fact, we even keep track of a
lot of the requests that are
served out of our edge caching
infrastructure.
Obviously, those won't be any
of the source of dynamic
errors, and we present that
all in a near real-time
information.
If App Engine itself is down,
we also have the Google App
Engine Notify groups.
Your application at any one time
is currently only served
out of a single data center.
We do that for latency
reasons.
One is that if you're using
Cloud SQL, for example, we
want to make sure that it's in
the same data center, but that
all the ancillary services are
living with your application.
And we failover very seamlessly
between data centers.
But the important thing to note
is that your application
is currently only running in
one data center at a time.
So when you're troubleshooting
things, you don't have to
worry about different data
centers to look at.
App Engine could possibly be
down in one data center, and
all the applications could be
served over in a different
data center very quickly.
The Google App Engine Downtime
Notify tells you if there's a
system-wide issue.
You also see our Status
Dashboard, which shows
aggregated metrics from apps
that we have running in
different data centers.
We're trying to give you a
snapshot of what's different
at our infrastructure, and you
can see in your individual
application it might
be different.
Here's what the App Engine Admin
Console looks like, and
this will tell you a
lot of information.
Just simply, is your application
serving, how many
different instances it has
running, and the average query
per second, or QPS.
It's great.
It's what I always look at
first when I'm trying to
troubleshoot a problem.
And what you'll see very quickly
is if you've run out
of quota, it's going to actually
show you the quota
that you've run out of.
And if there's additional quotas
that aren't shown on
the Dashboard Page that you've
run into, it will actually add
them to the bottom of the
screen and show a little
exclamation mark notifying
you that you've
hit some errors there.
Perhaps the most important
page is that dashboard.
The next one was instances
discussed earlier.
And thirdly is the logs.
There's a lot of great
information in those logs that
cover what your application
is doing, who accessed the
application and from which IP.
If the instance is still
running, then you can also see
inside that log a link
straight to the
logs for that instance.
So now, if you see an error
that's happening, you can very
quickly see what's causing
the problem.
And just like in a traditional
environment running in
individual machines, it's not
unheard of for an individual
machine to actually
have problems.
We see that from time to time,
and we try to catch all those
challenges or those
bugs on our side.
And not even letting us
deploy application.
And that's how we use the App
Master to coordinate which
servers are currently hosting
applications in our
environment.
But in some cases, there might
be corrupt memory.
There might be something wrong
with that local disk drive,
and your application may be
spinning some errors.
And if you see a lot of errors
from one instance, you can
shut down that instance, and it
will spin a new instance up
on a different machine.
Now, that's very rare, but it
may happen, and so it's
something to look into.
If you see this a lot, or if you
notice it, we'd appreciate
it if you could open a support
ticket so that we could
identify which ones were causing
errors and why it
caused errors that our system
didn't catch so that we can
improve the server so
that it doesn't
slip through the cracks.
So let's discuss the logs.
Whenever you express those tech
issues, obviously there's
going to be a lot of information
in the logs.
We store a free 1 gigabyte of
data at a timeline of 90 days.
If you want to store more or
longer, we just charge you at
$0.24 per gigabyte per month,
and you can use APIs to pull
those logs and keep them
on a separate system.
A lot of companies copy their
logs over to Google Cloud
Storage for our long term
storage where you can do some
transformation, import them
into BigQuery and do some
analytics across them.
In addition to just the simple
logs, you can do a system.out
to write to the logs if you
specify that the log handler
should be at a level info or
lower, meaning info debugging.
Otherwise, you can also write
straight to the log with a
normal logging mechanism.
But since we do charge for
that storage, I would
recommend against storing a
lot of information for all
your production applications.
It might make sense to do some
testing and then lower the log
just for the same reason
you do that in a local
environment.
Now when you look at the
logs, there's a few
things to keep in mind.
We do present the millisecond
response time.
The CPU response time also
in milliseconds.
And then the cost.
We touch more on how you'd
estimate those costs later,
but this gives you a
relative indicator.
So if you're trying two
different functions out, you
could see if one ends
up costing more.
That means that it spends more
time processing it and
therefore is more expensive
whether or not it may have
been faster for a variety
of different reasons.
Perhaps you're doing API request
to other libraries or
a URL fetch the could have
added a lot of delay, but
doesn't actually require compute
processing power.
What do you think is one of the
most common issues we see
across the board?
What most people do is launch
their app, and they think they
could scale infinitely.
But they forgot to enable
billing, and they wonder why
it stops working after a certain
amount of requests.
We have a whole quota system,
and there's good reason why.
It's not just for the billing
purpose, but since we have a
shared infrastructure, we want
to make sure that everybody
has enough room to
grow and play.
And so, we have some built-in
quotas that
you can consume against.
This would be things such
as incoming and outgoing
bandwidth, the Datastore usage,
the different amounts
of mail that you could send, but
we also have others like
the static code that
you've stored.
In fact, if you look at the
quota detail page, there's a
huge list of different things
we have quotas for.
A quota exceeded error is just
simply that you've run out of
a quota in one of these buckets
when you've tried to
perform the operation.
So it's entirely possible that
you have a lot of quota left
over for actually running
the application.
For example, perhaps this task
queue you've hit 100,000
times, and you've hit the quota
limit for it, so the
task queue starts
throwing errors.
So you might think that
something's wrong in the
infrastructure.
It takes you a while to finally
realize that you've
just run out of task
queue quota.
It would have been very simple
if you went to the dashboard,
but then maybe they went
straight to the logs.
Start digging.
That's why you want to
look at the dashboard
first before the logs.
We have a couple of different
types of quotas which could
confusing to new developers
in the cloud platform.
We have two different types.
We have a daily quota where I
think of it as a bunch of
tokens in a bucket, and every
time you perform a task, it
pulls a token from
that bucket.
And if you've run out over
the period of the day,
then you've run out.
You have to wait for the next
reset period, which happens at
10 AM Pacific Time.
We also have a per-minute quota,
and the reason why we
do this is we don't want one app
to drain all the resources
in a data center.
Believe it or not, that's
entirely possible.
We use the same infrastructure
for our web crawler that we
use for the URL fetch.
So we put these quotas on
there so that you can't
consume too fast
in one minute.
The same as the concept as the
daily token or the daily
bucket, is we have a bucket for
each minute that we keep
throwing tokens in every single
minute, and then you
pull from that.
And if you've run out in a
minute, you just have to wait
for that minute to finish to
replenish that bucket.
And then you continue
processing.
Now we have usually two
different limits.
We have one limit for free apps
and a different limit for
billed apps.
Once you enable billing, we have
your credit card, we know
who you are, so we trust
you a little more.
And we know who to knock on
the door, so to speak, if
something goes wrong or a
card that we can charge.
So that's why you'll see
two different limits.
But almost all of the limits
that we have are completely
soft limits.
And so, if there's an
application that, for example,
needs to open a million channel
calls in a minute
because you have a huge site
that a lot of people are going
to connect to, we
can handle that.
Just you need to talk to us so
that we can understand what
you're trying to do.
And when you're doing it at that
scale, a lot of times we
might ask a few questions to
make sure that you're doing it
appropriately and
not trying to do
something kind of abusive.
Or maybe there's a better
way to do it that
we can talk to you.
The way you would open those,
or talk to us, would be
typically through our Premier
support, opening a ticket
through that.
And so, I can't stress enough
that I keep mentioning you'd
want to open a ticket or you'd
want to talk to us.
The best way to do that is by
having a Premier account.
If you guys don't have a Premier
account, I recommend
doing it, getting through the
process of getting that set up
so you can submit tickets and
our team can interact with you
very efficiently.
One additional suggestion, you
can specify your application
either single-thread
or multi-thread.
If your code could handle
multiple threads, obviously
it's much more efficient
to do that.
Otherwise, your single instance
can only respond to
one request at a time.
Ultimately, it tends to cost
less for a multi-threaded
application.
So let's talk about quotas
for incoming and outgoing
bandwidth, and this is just
one example from our
documentation.
As I mentioned, we have lots of
quotas, and so you have to
go online to see all of them.
But here's where we could
specify if we have outgoing
bandwidths for the free limit
and then for billing-enabled.
So you'll see that daily
limit go from a
gigabyte to 14 terabytes.
Just a small jump, but also from
56 megs a minute to 10
gigs a minute.
So we actually, even once you've
enabled billing, we
already have a pretty
high quota.
We just need to talk
to support and see
how you can do that.
And by the way, if you plan on
launching on Monday, don't
open a ticket on Friday night.
Give us at least a week
at a minimum.
The longer you give us, the
better, because it sometimes
has to involve engineering, and
they actually sometimes
have to change code.
Because if we're going over a
big spike, we'll create a
whole new bucket system for
maybe just your app.
So again, free incoming
bandwidth, same thing.
Since we don't have the same
abuse issues for incoming
bandwidth, meaning as we would
for outgoing, we've obviously
higher limits.
And a lot of things, too, is
from an infrastructure
perspective.
We have more data going out than
we do in, so it's a lot
easier for us to say, sure, go
ahead and send it since our
pipes are bidirectional.
So here's the details page for
quotas, and this is where it
lists a huge variety of
quotas that we have.
And there's many more that
aren't even shown here that we
can see internally just so it
doesn't confuse you as well as
tell us more about our
infrastructure.
But this should give you a good
snapshot of where you are
in your quota.
What this shows is the daily
quota, and typically, we'll
show you the free, and a lot of
times you'll see the free
consumption here, and
it will show red.
But that just means that you
start paying for that.
And there'll maybe be another
entry later that says, but
your larger quota
may be greater.
Know that this may slightly
different between the online
billing and a Premier-enabled
account.
So how would you handle these
quota errors that you get?
But you can also catch these
exceptions as they happen.
So for example, if your
application still works fine,
but your task queue runs out
of quota, you could handle
that gracefully.
And the way you do that is in
Java, we throw over quota
exceptions.
Or in Python, we give it
an over quota error.
So you're always going to
want to check it in your
application when you've
run into this.
If you're using the task queue,
for example, it may
throw an error which you'll just
put it back in the task
queue and will retry later.
So maybe that's an acceptable
thing, to just simply let
throw a non-success code
for the HTTP request.
But just keep in mind of
the cost benefit of it.
Is it really worth doing all
this capturing of errors in
order to provide the
experience I want?
So you've hit quota errors.
Like I talked about earlier,
if you haven't enabled
billing, you're going to
have lower quotas.
So the first thing you want
to do is enable billing.
Then you can set a budget on
the different resources.
Something to consider, though,
is you don't have the ability
to set maximum charges
on your application.
If you have a new developer in
your team that launches a task
queue with an endless loop
that spins up a lot of
instances, for example, you're
going to pay for that, and
there's no way to stop that.
I've seen a lot of customers do
development on online apps,
and most of development
can be free if they
don't hit the quotas.
Their only production
applications are in their
Premier account.
That's certainly a way
of addressing it.
So when I talk about setting
a budget, that doesn't just
apply to Premier accounts.
So you'd enable the billing by
going to the Admin Console,
and then the Billing Status, and
then just enable billing.
And when you do that, it
actually uses our Google
Wallet now to get your credit
card information and start
billing you, so you'll have to
have a Google Wallet account
in order to do this.
And we'll charge the credit
card, but what's nice is if
you go to Wallet, you can also
see the past invoices, as well
as on the app console.
You'll see all the information
there.
All the different usage we have
has corresponding dollar
amounts with it.
And once you enable billing,
you still get all your free
quotas, and we only start
charging you once you go
beyond that free quota.
Also worth noting is that if
you have billing enabled,
we'll charge you a minimum of
$2.10 a week, and any usage
that your app has will be
subtracted from that.
So for example, if you have $5
in usage, you only pay $5
because that's more
than $2.10.
If you have zero usage for that
week, you'll still be
charged $2.10.
And once you enable billing,
it's just over in our system
making sure that it's serious.
And there's also abuse
vectors inside here.
So for example, once you enable
billing, we wait until
a certain number of our charges
have cleared so that
we know the credit card is valid
before we allow you to
send a large number of emails.
We've noticed by doing that, it
cut down significantly on
spammers using our system
to send email.
So there's also reasons
for that, and
that's part of the $2.10.
Frankly, we're not getting
rich off of the $2.10.
It's just to gate people that
aren't serious about this and
would commit fraud from actually
enabling billing.
If you have more than 1 gig in
your logs, for example, you
have to enable billing
in or just do that.
You also have certain
features.
Like the minimum max idle
instances, I think, might be
something you'd need billing
enabled for.
There's some tweaks like that
when you go into your app, if
it doesn't work exactly the way
your production app does,
it might be because the billing
is not enabled.
Now for the Frontend
Instance Hours.
This is confusing to some people
because of the invoices
in the billing.
We only charge instance hours.
We don't charge instance
sizes.
And the way we do that
is every multiple.
What you can do then, once
you've enabled billing, is you
can set a daily max budget, and
that's very helpful for
situations where you have an
endless loop, or a mistake, or
you accidentally started writing
billions of objects in
the Datastore, then you
have to go back
and delete all those.
The way to prevent that from
running out of control is to
set the max daily budget, and we
can also specify discounted
instance hours.
It lets us do better capacity
planning because you'd set
this for your application.
And that pretty much means
you're going to consume
however many instance hours per
week, or you're going to
pay us that regardless,
or if not, you use it.
So that allows us to ramp up
our capacity to meet the
demands as planned, and we pass
on some cost savings.
So rather than the $0.08 per
hour, we're only going to
charge you $0.05 per hour.
This means that if you put in
500 instance hours here, that
means your app will consume
500 hours over
the course of a week.
And so every hour that's
consumed, we
take from that bucket.
And as soon as you've depleted
that bucket, we just continue
serving the application, but
at the $0.08 per hour rate,
not the discounted $0.05 per
instance hour, for example.
Now, since we don't have
the ability to set this
information for Premier
accounts, all instances are
charged at $0.05 per instance
hour for Premier accounts.
So, another great reason to
get a Premier account, not
only you get the support, the
SLA, but you also get the
discount on all your frontend
consumption.
Another thing that I've seen
people run into is they enable
billing because they've
run out of quota.
It may take some time for our
system to process it, so you
can expect a 15 to 20 minute
delay from when you enable
billing to actually getting
the benefits.
In some cases, like that email,
we don't actually
increase the quota until we've
cleared at least one charge.
Finally, here's a list of
resources of both documents
and articles that you might
be interested in pursuing
further, information on
managing your app.